des juifs des musulmans des chrétiens
les communautés religieuses ont répondu
à l'invitation lancée par le cames 78 le
collectif des associations musulmanes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et de ses
environs organisait son quatrième dîner
annuel en plein ramadan le rendez-vous a
débuté par les discours objectif montrer
la cohésion entre les représentants des
différents cultes du territoire il ya
toujours besoin de rappel et pas de
rappel nécessairement aux personnes de
cette assemblée la mais peut-être le
rappelle qu'il faut qu'on soit tous
vigilants ensemble face à une ambiance
qui n'est peut-être pas des meilleures
un climat qui peut qu'il faut être
anxiogène c'est une opportunité de
dialogue et de fraternité
et je crois que au jour le jour la paix
sociale se construit comme ça par la
connaissance réciproque et le dialogue
ensemble je crois que nous sommes sur la
bonne voie pour donner exemple à la
jeunesse du coi exemple de rapports
harmonieux dans la salle et sur la scène
des personnalités politiques du
département des maires de toute
étiquette le président du département
pierre bédier le préfet jean-jacques
brot ou encore des députés je crois que
le fait qu'on soit là en tant que
parlementaire en tant que représentant
de l'état s'est démontré que la concorde
républicaine c'est d'arriver justement à
ce que ensemble dans une même salle
quelles que soient nos convictions
religieuses qu'on aime qu'on n'en ai pas
on est en capacité ensemble de faire
nation et ça c'est ce que nous permet la
laïcité et je pense que être présent
c'est finalement porter notre témoignage
a star la soirée s'est terminée par une
rupture du jeûne du ramadan entre les
100 invités présents le rendez vous
devrait à nouveau être organisées
l'année prochaine par le cames 78